hello everyone and welcome to
today's webinar quality control in the
hematology lab i am cristian
leiva from abbott hematology and i will be your
moderator for today's event
this educational webinar is
hosted by la bruce and brought to
you by abbott diagnostics
For more information about it you
can visit the website www
dot laboratory dot abbott is more
hematology
before we start I would like to
remind you that it is inside it is
interactive we invite you to participate
if I understand the questions you want at
the time you want during the
presentation to  Simply
write your question in the
ask box and click submit We will
answer as many questions
as time allows at the end of the
presentation If you have
trouble viewing or listening to the presentation
click the support tab
at the bottom of the presentation  upper right
of the presentation window or report
of your pr  Problem by clicking on the
access ask a question located on
the far left of the screen
this presentation is educational and
therefore offers continuing education credits
please click on the
continuing education credits tab
located on the top right of
the window  presentation and follow the
process to obtain your credits
now I will introduce you to our
speaker today the doctor is in
huelva who is the current director of
customer services and technology
back from webber using he is also the one who
manages the website the portal of
courses and  The company's blog is
involved in creating online
training administration
editing and writing reports
essays and applications on
quality control method validation and sigma and
other laboratory management topics
for a full biography
on our speaker visit the
bio access at the top
of your screen is important  It is worth mentioning
that this virtual seminar is a
repetition translated into Spanish in the
original version transmitted by this
same means that in 2018
we will now start our presentation
welcome to today's h and tea series
sponsored by abbott diagnostics the
oil series are virtual seminars
and presentations
hematology and hemostasis live sessions designed
to help abbott customers
learn more about innovations and
clinical approaches that can support
their laboratories' goal of
achieving better performance in
healthcare my name is esten westward
and the  today's topic is
quality control in the hematology laboratory i
want to start of course with a
standard statement that abbott
laboratories is supporting my time and
my presentation there is a more
orthodox statement that should be particularly
for those of you attending
a seminar  virtual need to know
which huéscar they are esc  There are two
webs cards but you may only be
familiar with the first webs gracq
I am known simply as a
western which while my father is
known as the webs farc so if you
have heard of the rules of huéscar they
are my father's creation  and I,
like you, have been following them
for the last 30 years. I only have
about 25 years in this field, while
my father is celebrating his 50 years of
contribution to laboratory medicine,
what we do in addition to training is to
provide a series  of resources
through the internet to laboratories
around the world we have westgate dotcom
a membership site that has more
than 59 thousand laboratory professionals it
is a free membership and if they
sign up they will have access to more than 600
different articles essays lessons
etcetera that  they have to do with
quality control we also have a
course portal where we carry out
structured training and a blog  in
which we cover shorter articles
news and most importantly
questions and answers
the agenda for
today's webinar begins with a review of
our current
quality control practices in hematology after
doing a review we will look at some of
the most frequently asked questions  Common and
Ignored Recommendations on
Quality Control in
Hematology We'll even take a closer look at
how common poor
quality control practices are
in hematology and then
suggest a solution for a new
generation of quality control practices.
quality control that combine the power
of webber's rules with the power of six
sigma and the ability to
quantitatively determine the frequency of your
quality control
when it comes to hematology in the
laboratory there are a number of articles
that have come out in the last decade that
have  questioned the level of quality
that is being applied for example in
this doc  As of 2010, it was stated that
many of the
current quality control procedures are not specific
to hematology and lead to non-
productive practices which is consistent with the
fact that we have very
advanced engineering and some analyzers in
hematology that are in their
fourth or fifth generation another study
published in 2012 that only analyzed the
basophil count found that three out
of three instruments, that is, 100% of
the methods they observed, were
providing unsatisfactory quality
low correlation in the
basophil count between the different
instruments and different to the  value of
the reference method
this can of course be something that is not
only important to the laboratory
in terms of its own ability to
maintain quality control but
can be disclosed and really
impact patients in a dramatic way
also a study done in  2009
on the methods of measurement of
plaqu  etas in three
different automated hematology analyzers
found that his transfusion was performed
due to the data reported by
all study analyzers and of
course under transfusion can be a
big problem for patient care
we have papers going back a
decade and  which suggest that the
quality is not as good or as reliable
in hematology analyzers as
we hope or wish
there are additionally some other
questions that arise when people
adapt what we might call the
traditional
clinical chemistry quality control approach to
conditions
Hematology Analyzer Specials
Some of the questions we
frequently get on the
huéscar website are can you use
the manufacturer's mean and standard deviation
when it comes to quality control in
hematology can you use the controls
provided by the manufacturer can you
use the  control ranges that are
they provide in the insert do i have to
use huescar rules in
hematology or should i avoid them a
very specific question for
hematology is our controls have
such a short shelf life its not too
hard to establish the true mean and
standard deviation for those controls
when talking  of the mean and the
standard deviation of the manufacturer
we refer to the iso 15 189 standard
and the technical requirement
specifically says that the laboratory must
design internal quality control systems
that verify the achievement of the
expected quality of the results and
that the design means  that you have to
choose the control rules the
control numbers and the frequency
you have to verify that the performance is
acceptable and that you are trying to
meet some level of
expected quality and that expected quality
is usually based on a
specification  performance analytics
the use of manufacturer's controls
is not recommended by  the iso 189
standard instead recommends using
independent third party checks it is
only in the latest version of iso 15 189
where this recommendation has been added
typically followers of docs
did 15 189 will notice if something is
recommended in this version and it is a
recommendation  optional is a sign
that the next version will probably
make it a mandatory requirement
therefore
independent third party checks
could become a
mandatory requirement of any lab
did 15 189 that's the future
we're headed towards the reason why  why
even a doc standard
like 15 189 did recommend this
third party control is because there is too much
evidence of manufacturer controls
being adjusted or tampered with and
the control lot synchronizing with
our new reagent lot
this results in a loss  of the
objective capacity to detect
variations, changes and errors
clinically
I would like to tell people that
when they use a manufacturer control
sometimes what is happening is that the
manufacturer is controlling them in
chemistry we have a very well
recognized problem of this where these
manufacturer controls are not very sensitive to
actual errors because of  This is very well indicated in the
best practice documents for the field of
chemistry. The best
practice for laboratories is to have
independent third-party controls.
I can use the manufacturer's control ranges.
Here we can see a document
h 26 to 2 of the cls and  this is the second
accepted version and it is a standard or
should I say guideline that lists the
best practices for
quality assurance in hematology the cls and
says the laboratory should establish its
own expected mean and
quality control values
but from the values ​​of  control
ranges provided by the manufacturer
are often too wide for
effective quality control  The problem
that occurs when using the
manufacturer's range is that the limits
typically stretch out too far from the
mean this will make your limits look
very allowable and they will compress your data
very close to the mean it will give you the
illusion that everything is under control
when  in fact they may be
effectively practicing quality control
blindly not catching errors that are
clinically important but the
way they build the
levy jennings control table makes it look like everything
is fine another frequently asked question is
should i avoid using wyngard's rules
In hematology
this often occurs when we are talking about
manufacturer control ranges and two
standard deviation limits
there is a particular problem when
a full set of Huescar multiple rules is used
in hematology quality control tables in
particular the 10x rule  so the
guideline of the cls and vice
multi r parsing is strongly recommended
eglas which means huesca rules which
also points out that decisions
based solely on plus or minus two
standard deviations are too
simplistic and that they are insufficient then they
cite huesca that here they
are probably citing the wizard and not
me the traditional use of  12 s as
a warning control rule is no longer
recommended instead
the recommendation is a
hierarchical selection of multiple
specific rules that maximize pv which
stands for error detection and
minimize pf r which stands for false
rejection
that phrase alludes to some
advanced techniques  which we will introduce in the
last part of this webinar
but essentially it says don't use the rule
of 2s and apply your huescar rules
but don't light them on everything don't
use huescar rules on all
parameters but use the ones that shape the
approach in  It shapes the number of
rules to use based
on method performance on an as-
needed basis.  data of your patient
and the way to determine which is the
best fit is by looking at the
different sets of rules and seeing
which one provides the best error detection
but also minimizes your false rejection or
te fr once again the way to do it is
by applying the approach  six sigma
our last question is isnt it
too hard to set the mean and
standard deviation when my
controls have such a short shelf life
this is a chronic problem for
quality controls in all
hematology labs where having
a month of stability can be
Typically you're lucky if you get
two months of stability so
by the time they've
collected 20 data points which is
usually the minimum to set their
own mean and standard deviation they're
almost at the end of the useful life of that
control one solution is to make a
control overlay then as
the previous control batch is
ending  or they should start the new
control batch three to five days in
advance and during those thirteen five
days they should do multiple measurements
to collect those 20 data points
in advance so that by the
time the last batch is actually
finished they will have one ready.  new mean
and new standard deviation can
make the change the new
QC lot and actually have
enough data to go on
if they don't like that length of
overlap another solution is to use
only eight overlapping values ​​to
have the new control lot and
run eight controls and from
there calculate the new mean
there is a rule of thumb that eight
values ​​are enough
to reliably establish a new mean it is
not reliable enough to establish
a new standard deviation but if you
have the new mean you can use the
old one  coefficient of variation and make
a temporary set of new bounds
control
limits can see the equation right there new mean times old cb to get a temporary standard deviation and that they can use that to plot their
control limits and they should only use those
temporary control limits long
enough to accumulate those 20
data points to  be able to get the new
mean and new standard deviation
then that way they will have all the
correct data to correctly create
their control charts
a third solution is to use a running
mean and standard deviation
from multiple control lots
if we look at the guideline of  24
says that 3 to 6 months of getting the
cumulative values ​​for the mean and
standard deviation gives you a
stable and reliable consistent specification
for the mean and standard deviation
for solutions 2 and 3
we are assuming there is not much
difference between each  batch of
hematology controls so if you see that there is a
big difference between each batch of  e
hematology controls solutions
2 and 3 are probably not appropriate
because they are going to have two very
different performances if you try to average them
or combine them to get
temporary control limits you won't get something that
really reflects the actual performance
of either one
this  brings us to the end of the
most frequently asked questions now we will answer how
common are poor
quality control practices in hematology
we did a survey in 2016 we received
responses from over 900 laboratories from
over 100 countries to be fair
most responses were from
chemistry laboratories but of those
responses we got around 100
of them that were from
hematology laboratories or laboratories that
shared their
hematology quality control practices with us
therefore we can delve into the frequency
of problems in the field of
hematology we can  see in the first
question that about 70% something
less than 70% of laboratories
claim they are using two
standard deviation limits for
pathology quality control this is in
contrast to what we see in chemistry
where it is only 55% this is an
outdated practice two
standard deviations are around  50 years ago
when labs were just
starting to do quality control they
used to use standard deviation limits
everything else in the lab
of course has changed but we seem to be
burdened by this legacy of
history or this tradition of using two
standard deviations the larger  The problem
with two standard deviations is that it
can give you an expected false rejection rate
of 59 or 14 percent
depending on whether you are processing one,
two or three checks per run
if you have something as high as 14
percent rejection you are passing the most
part of your time chasing
ghosts these are problems you don't
really need to chase no
they represent a real problem so
this is a technique they should have
abandoned
also we see about 70% of
the labs are using
huéscar rules for some tests and that
is almost in line with chemistry in
chemistry is a bit higher
about  78 percent of the
time chemistry labs
use huescar rules and
obviously the benefit of
huescar rules is that it maximizes error detection
but minimizes their false rejection
therefore still gives them the
error detection they would like  having
the two standard deviation bounds
used to give you but you don't have those
false rejection issues of the two
standard deviation bounds instead
of 14% false rejection it goes down
to 1 or 2 percent or a maximum of 3
percent  percent of false rejects
when laboratories are choosing
their control ranges you can see
that there are two main ways
indicated in this table  56% of
labs report using the
manufacturer's range so what we
told them they shouldn't be doing
that's what they do most of the
time but right behind that 53%
of labs also report that it will
actually calculate  in the mean and
standard deviation this is in line
with what we see in chemistry as well
although in chemistry we see more
labs choosing their own mean and
standard deviation doing their own
work and then using the
manufacturer's range so hematology
is  a bit behind in
moving away from
manufacturers' ranges compared to
chemistry
when looking at the type of
controls hematology labs use
almost 80% of
labs only use
manufacturer's controls this is much higher than
what we see in clinical chemistry where it
's only two thirds about 30%
of laboratories are using quality
controls  third party liquid and
assayed this is a bit lower than what
we see in chemistry where that figure
is 37% an interesting finding is the
use of
normal QC average or what some people call
patient data QC
or what you may know
as the pop algorithm indicates that almost a
quarter of hematology labs
are using that type of
technique that quality control based
on patient data
that's much higher than what we see
in chemistry where  it's half that
number only 12% of chemistry labs
use that technique and that
technique is very powerful and very useful
so this is an area where
hematology is really the
main area of ​​the lab when it
comes to control of  patient quality
now how often do
labs do their
quality control 41% of hematology labs
do it once a day that
's a little lower than l  or what we see
in chemistry where from 47% the other
number that we see that is quite
different is almost a quarter of the
labs are processing three times
a day or probably once a shift
almost double what we see in chemistry
in  chemistry is much more fixed
quality control is done once a day
while hematology partly
due to regulations are often
encouraged to run control more than
once a day
what happens when hematology labs
have an event outside
control how they troubleshoot
their runaway event well 80%
of them do what we want them to do
which is troubleshoot really look for
the root cause and before
they even consider running a
control again actually try to find
the cause  source of the problem but more than
that 86% of the laboratories are
repeating the control they see that the
value is out and cross their fingers and
hope that repeating it will
simply  mently it will fall back within the
expected
that number is a little higher than what we
see in chemistry where less than three
quarters of the laboratories will repeat the
control but you can also see that if
the first repeat control does not work
almost 60% of  labs are
willing to set up and run a
new control so if they get a
control that's out they repeat it if it's
still out then use on a new one
and then 20 percent of
labs repeat the new control if
it's not already in  they're essentially
running four times the
hope that a value will fall back
within the expected ranges and this
iteration and iteration and
iteration responds to what we often
call the bet type quality control
you're only trying to roll the
dice once  more and hope that the
numbers that appear make it seem like you
have regained control how
often these types of events occur
that indicate you are out of c  ontrol in
hematology good 40%
of hematology labs report that it
happens once a day more than once a
day or once every few days so it
's happening quite frequently
all these problems that we see with
quality control in hematology
because so many out of control events are happening they
are really a burden
to your lab operations
it wouldn't be too bad to repeat the checks
but only if we are out of control
once a month
might we be willing to accept that
kind of provisional or imperfect protocol
if we weren't seeing so
many out of control results but if
we have out of control results
every day or several times a day
then that really is telling us
that we are overwhelmed by
outliers we are overwhelmed by
red flags and what we risk is
staying  deaf it is possible that we
stop hearing these alarms because
we receive them very often
and  This is a condition that is well
known in clinical circles
particularly with
electronic medical records when I am going to talk
about alert fatigue which typically
describes what happens when a doctor
gets too
many pop up warnings they get so many warnings
that they get used to doing  click on them
and dismiss them and you
can actually miss very important alarms the
same thing can happen in our
QC we have so many QC alarms
that we think
are not a real problem and we'll just
repeat the check until it gets
in range but  in fact there may be a
real situation out of control that is going to
affect patients and we ignore it we write it
off because we think it's
another one of those false rejects
this corrosive problem means we
have labs that will report
patient samples even though
their  quality control has told them that they
are out of control cer  About 9%
of labs will report
patient results despite
being out of control on a daily weekly or
monthly basis that's actually quite a bit
less than what we see in chemistry
where one in ten labs
are reporting these results when they
are  out of control the last
question we asked the
laboratories in the survey is, have you
really changed the way you do
quality control?
we run our
quality control it's the same
quality control we've been doing
for the last 10 or 20 or 30 years
this is higher than what we see in
chemistry where over 61 percent
of labs say they haven't done
any  change but not as high
as 78% apparently it seems like
quality control practices have
been in a kind of stasis or
bucket state for quite some time  and a
lot of bad habits have built up now that
we've cataloged all of our
problems and really explored
how prevalent those problems are
we want to move on to suggest some
solutions just as you
probably installed or added
a state of the art hematology instrument
to your lab
we're going  to introduce a state of the art type
of quality control
this will be more than just the
huesca rules which will be the huescar rules
plus the addition of the six sigma technique and
something we just added in the last
year which is the ability to determine
quantitatively and scientifically the
frequency of quality control
i.e. the frequency with which
quality control should be processed
the core of the six sigma approach is to
compare its quality
on this scale of 0 to 6 there is a
universally accepted scale of 0 to 6 in  The
6 Sigma sigma performance benchmark is world-class performance
and that s  means less than 4
defects per million reports
so if you have a million
test results and it's at 6 sigma
then less than 4 of
those results are expected to be defective or
erroneous or false positives or
false negatives this  it's essentially
all the more defect-free
what you'll find is that if you're at 6
sigma your lab operations
become more efficient
your test results become more effective
because your doctor knows it and is pretty
sure those results are reliable  and
exact, the other end of the
sigma scale is typically considered 3 sigma,
that is, the minimum acceptable performance
is 3 sigma, this corresponds to about 67
thousand defects per million reports
outside of health care if you
are at three sigma or less in the industry.
manufacturers would be thinking of
radically improving or redesigning or
even replacing any process that
has a performance that is
pr  problematic
a 3 sigma or two sign process
really consumes too much time
money and effort in a lab or
manufacturer or any kind of
industrial process they are really generating
too many defects which makes them
solve more problems spend more time
tracking re doing their work
having to do multiple  testing
to get a correct answer
really ends up being too expensive to
maintain such a low sigma process
of course because there are so many
defects many of them could be
disclosed and reach patients and
impact them adversely when
we apply six sigma the
hematology when we talk about
laboratory tests we
need a number that tells us how
good each parameter should be in
other words for leukocytes
how good we have to be to
provide accurate results and
support the best patient care there are
many different sources of these
requirements  of quality or
analytical performance specifications for example in
this first column
cl these are the
usa regulations and it directly regulates one two three
four five different parameters in
germany there are the really back rules
that actually specify the
laboratory comparison targets for
four parameters there is something called  the
rico database and the most
recent version we have available was
published in 2014 based on studies of
biological variation they can specify
for almost every parameter in
hematology how good you need to be
to be as good as possible given the
known variation  that the body
introduces in these laboratory tests
the final column is actually a
kind of consensus statement of
the Spanish groups in their app or
aptitude tests they looked at the reality of
the results of the
competition tests of their member laboratories
and  they tried to find out which are the
laboratories capable of  s to achieve that they are
trying to figure out if there are some
goals that are so small that no one
can achieve them
what is a more practical goal and what
today's technology can achieve out
of all those different resources
we make this recommendation for their
common parameters use the
cl targets
for your differential counts use
rico's targets and then there are times
when you're going to want to rely on the
spanish consensus target
rico's targets for leukocytes
erythrocytes hemoglobin and hematocrit are so
small that really no
methodology  commercially available is
capable of reaching 4 5 or 6 sigma so
maybe the next generation of
instruments will be able to achieve those
targets but it's not something we should
expect to see in the next few years once
we have those total permissible error targets
we can use them as context
and introduce our bias and our
impression and that allows us to calculate
our score  sigma metric as you can see
at the bottom of the slide
our sigma metric is the total
allowable error that was on the previous slide
then we subtract the absolute percentage bias
that we might be getting
from our peer group or our
apt program or our  comparison
of our actual control mean
vs. the target mean then we divide that
number by the print or you see that is
of course what we
routinely get from our controls
here is a westward sigma rule it's
the traditional huéscar rules but
there are some vertical lines  blues
dividing the huescar rules into
different sigma zones if you are in the
6 sigma zone you will notice the
blue line appears and you really only
need to use one huescar rule if
you have a 6 sigma hematology method you do
n't really need all the
rules  of huéscar can establish their
limits in 13 s or 3
standard deviations of the measurement  so if you look further down
below that six sigma number it
gives you an estimated run size and it says
1000 patient samples that means
for every 1000 patient samples
tested you
should run a quality control
that is the way to minimize the risk
of  impact even
one patient outcome with a clinically
significant error then looking the
other way horizontally going to 5
sigma the run size goes down to 450
4 sigma goes down to 200 and 3 sigma goes down to 45 you
can see that as  who have more
sigma run QC
less frequently and with fewer rules
but as their sigma goes down they will
need more huescar rules and
have to run
QC more frequently
when life gets tougher the
lower the sign
In conclusion I want to convey the
message that we really need to
improve the way
quality control is done hematology there are
many practices
common counterproductives in the field at this time and
we should move away from manufacturer controls
manufacturer ranges and
interference should be avoided and should
move towards their own means their
own standard deviation and use
independent third party controls if they
have 6 sigma performance or  5 sigma
or even 4 sigma will get some
real benefits from applying this
more advanced technique of combining
Huescar rules with sigma and then
modifying the frequency
of QC processing we already see in
chemistry and hopefully soon in
hematology that by  apply this in
laboratories around the world those
six sigma parameters get
financial benefits from the reduction in the number
of huéscar rules that are
implemented from the reduction
in the number of controls that need to
be processed and will actually see a
reduction in the number of
outliers that are flagged by your system
because there are m  Many that you might
think were errors that now won't be
clinically significant won't
consider them real errors you
might see a 10x but if your method is
four or five or six sigma that
10x violation isn't really that
important
to hematology that's  a really
good thing because that 10x is probably
one of the most common errors or
common problems that they see
as controls get to end of
life they start to drift and
change and now we have a way of
telling that change could happen but
we are not going to have to worry that
we have to reject the execution
so we have a way to adjust
because we know a lot about the
performance of the method
now we are ready to hear your
questions we
appreciate the presentation the doctor
is in vietnam and now we will start a
round of questions  and live answers
about this virtual seminar
to answer your questions
join us  Ñan Raúl Jiménez Tito López and de
Miel Genuine, all of them specialists
in Abbott Hematology applications
for both the United States and
Latin America. They will be able to answer you
in Spanish or Portuguese, which is the
language of your question. We remind you that
to send your questions,
simply click on  the ask a question link on
the far
left of your screen we will answer as
many questions as
time allows let's get started this
first question is this
we are using an abos team that
owns internal controls made
by strikes and products by strikes  that they
consider these controls as from a
third party provider that is to say independent
help us
danielle
good afternoon everyone thank you kristen
they are considered because as the control
hell and manufactured by an
independent company and only
distributed by another rodent the team will be
awarded a against the independent third party
what  elderly  The problem with the
controls from the same provider, as the doctor says,
you have not studied, is that
in many cases the providers change
the controls to fit the
equipment
perfectly. Thank you, Daniel. We had the
following question,
what is the recommendation to use
moving averages,
the coefficient or algorithm?  by brian
bulls as an additional parameter to
guarantee an acceptable performance of the
instrument habits help us
good afternoon determine the average of
your population
these values ​​determine a range of
variation that controls each time you
go to a variation it means that
where
this variation occurred is a  interval given in
a routine if it is that it is a
variation interval this this integral and it came from
some specific place these collections
was made by the same person a
specific person a batch of tubes was used the
same as the others the equipment
before and
after behaved  also check with the
tubes we left behind
repeat this  e interval if it is only an
interval to verify that
the values ​​produce
in astrology we recommend using
barbi in moving averages at least
for the red series which consists of
monitoring three parameters
ok
perfect thanks víctor we have the
following question
which control rule is recommended to
use for  reject a run
currently in 1 to 2 s
12.5 s 1 to 3
efe help us raúl
hello good afternoon
this will depend on the sigma calculated
for each parameter and level of
control normal or high work in the
particular case of hematology in that process
in three  levels of control and at a
general level paradigms with very good
performance it is recommended to use 13 s and
for the more moderate ones it is recommended to
use 12.5 s in conjunction with other
rules such as those mentioned in this
presentation this is
what is called a scheme  multilingual
perfect thanks raúl we have here the
following question how is the
six sigma metric related to  the
quality control rules help us well
well the metric is called for the
procedure is that it will define the
crossover scheme that should be used
so when I have higher signs it
means that the frequency of errors
is peace then it can control fewer
plus signs  low
error frequencies higher therefore it has to
control more
perfect environment phrase we have here
the following question
what can we do when manufacturers
imply different coefficients of
variation in the different
concentrations of the controls this
because today we are verifying the
precision in the three  control levels
using this specification but
we know that this is not the reality
because different concentrations have
different coefficients of variation
vito helps us
and many times the manufacturers as he says
in the talk have some
procedures to adjust the
controls of their angles and many times they
are very  very long they are l  The same
for all levels, in these cases,
we do all the internal documentation, the
accuracy of the equipment, the maintenance documentation,
the contact with the
manufacturer to see if it was done for him,
it passes itself, it was an error in the
expertise in the instructions, everything is
It
is as expected. We use the range
since it is determined that the
laboratory is prepared to participate in an
external quality control group. This
is also a reference for your team
within your team. Work with him for
this control for this program.  with a
range within the expected within
the average of your methodology or your
group
this is also then being able to work
with a different angle that forms it is
the perfect double step
victor we have a question here
if I maintain the level of stigma and
hyperactivity  It is 500 daily
tests or control runs and it could be done
every 1000 tests, that is, every 48 written hours.
In this case, what happens is that  Because
the excitation regulations say that you have
to close the run, then yes, with a
system of six you can have
the sample, it has a run, but if it is
going to be changed, if it is going to be a shutdown of the
equipment, maintenance due to the change of
day, then it would be  It is more convenient to
close the analytical run with the 500
samples
is that it is said that if you are the one that
allows you to control up to a
thousand samples
but not necessarily
the gesture itself, thank you very much, here we have
another question, it
says how we should monitor the
parameters calculated in
theology, could you  help you detect yet
and thanks to cristian and in this in this
case
we are going to focus mainly on
the measured parameters there are also
specifications for
calculated parameters but the rules or multi
rules that we establish for our
control system must be focused
on the measured parameters
although good laboratory practice
is to
always have a control scheme for all
two parameters reported outside
the laboratory then two
calculated parameters are reported but again
if we have a measured parameter under
control it is very highly probable that the
calculating parameter is also
within control so in the
laboratories they can establish or decide
if they only focus the rules  the
multi rules in the measured ones or
these also apply to the
calculated parameters if there is a
quality specification for
perfect we have a question here
our team does not have an
interlaboratory control against it and we
have third opinion controls that
we can do in  Danielle can suddenly help us in this case
,
every Christian
in the case that there is no independent control,
the laboratory will have to establish its
means and standard deviations, as
I am already convinced, because in order to
have the most restrictive ranges,
which are normally the ranges of the
vendor manufacturer
though  Thank you, Raúl, so I think there is a
question in court and you can help us.
We are currently evaluating it
for me. I crossed out
and there are currently some articles.
Internal studies have already been published in
certain laboratories in Latin America and
obviously in the world where they have already
published value.  that is to say sigma for me
or you
but obviously
this activity is there this process can be
carried out in any of these
laboratories according to the
recommendations of doctor huesca in
this
perfect presentation here I have another question
and from there in weighted standard it is
too small so  that when fixing
it we do not easily get out this
standard deviation was obtained from three
batches suddenly raúl
if in this case this is one of the
most critical parts how to calculate the
standard regression
for our parameter then the
first thing to clarify is why
never use one  time that sounds standard
calculated with the ten or twenty runs
of the control batch
that we use to calculate the average
then for the measure it is fine but
not for the standard direction in this
case here it mentions that
the weighted average of the
principle of variation of three batches was calculated with the historical that
is fine although in reality we
recommend doing it with data from  six
months or if possible with six
different batches with the weighted mean of the
coefficient of variation
then but always keep in
mind that these data can be re-
evaluated because there may be
some bias in the data when you
had more
values ​​like
data laboratories then if the recommendation is
six batches if possible six months and
with this it is enough to have
an acceptable standard quote that is
not too tight
and if you feel that it is too tight
then you can reevaluate the data
when you have more  data available
perfect thanks we don't have time for
one last question if it is difficult to
achieve six sigma in hematology  ology, for
example, having three or four tops and
discarding the 10x rule for the
half-life of the control, how should
the half-life be handled because
recommendations should be followed to avoid
violating the strike rules, since
half-cocktail controls still tend
to present apparent changes in the
media era fears helps
and for description of life measurement of
controls are a great challenge in
hematology so what can be
done is to use the new scheme of
many rules of five rules that the
doctor is going to stretch presented then
with a sigma of three or  four could be to
use a run with 16 being 1
which would be the scheme with the rules 13 s
212 s r 4 s 41 s and 6 x that then it is
possible to do with three levels of
control that is the scheme is complicated
because it is used not  to five rules but
with a lower sign you have to have
more control over the
perfect process thanks to a said daniel for
solving these queries
again what  the questions we
could not answer we commit to
send it via email we
would like to thank the uis and our
sponsor border martiks for
sponsoring the educational seminar
and thank all the audience for
joining us and third interesting
questions
this virtual seminar that you will be able to watch
on demand  over the next six
months
labruce will notify you by
email when it is available
for playback we encourage you to share
this message with your colleagues who might
have missed the live event
again thank you very much and until
next time
bye